good afternoon
my name is Aaron Cummings I am just
absolutely thrilled to be here at
strange Loop to give a little talk about
Voyager Now Voyager is a a pair of twin
space probes these were launched back in
1977.
they're still out there returning data
from the the very edges of our solar
system the beginnings of interstellar
space
you can go out on jpl's jet propulsion
Laboratories web page and uh and
actually see where Voyager is
um right now
the the Voyager spacecraft have uh thus
far you know completed their initial
objective which was to visit Jupiter and
Saturn the mission was then extended for
Voyager 2 to visit Uranus and Neptune
and now 42 years after launch they're
still going they still operate we still
get Telemetry they're still responding
to commands this is the longest Mission
longest running mission that NASA has
ever had
it's been running so long that it used
to look like this this was the this logo
was brand new when Voyager launched
so in this talk I'm going to be
speaking about the the origins of the of
the Voyager Mission what things enabled
these missions to uh succeed and also
what has been contributing to the
longevity of the spacecraft and uh and
what's coming next
this is really about engineering and
systems and trade-offs I'm not going to
talk too much about the science of
Voyager
as far as why this talk why talk about
Voyager
well it's this
in the late 70s early 80s you see the
pictures come in in newspapers of what
Voyager is showing us and this is just
incredible I mean this is what's really
capturing the imagination
about myself I'm just a guy my day job
is programming and electronics I don't
have any connection to NASA nor to JPL
nor to the Voyager program so I don't
speak for them any opinions that might
be in this talk our our mind and not
those of NASA or JPL or my employer
so that out of the way the beginning
1964
an engineer at JPL Gary Flandreau he had
uh proposed a uh a mission a grand tour
to the outer planets
and this was something that was enabled
by an alignment of the four outer
planets Jupiter Saturn Uranus and
Neptune not that they were in a straight
line but a uh a good position so that
you could use a gravity assist maneuver
around one to get you until the next
and this enabled you to get to Neptune
in 12 years instead of say 30 if you had
tried to go there uh just in a straight
shot
so I think the first thing we'll say is
something about opportunity
if the planets literally align you might
want to take advantage of that situation
so let's build a deep space probe
we're in space because we want to learn
about it we need some instruments that
are going to be on here we need some way
to power those instruments we need to
get the data back from the probe so we
need a communication system we need
navigation propulsion stabilization keep
the thing pointed in the right direction
it needs to run for a decade or longer
without having any maintenance and we
need to be able to control this thing in
a non-real-time fashion because of the
speed of light
the space probes a long ways away bite
seems like it's really fast but I'm not
going to invoke Admiral Grace Hopper for
this one
a way to visualize the speed of light is
to take something a piece of wire maybe
this lanyard this is about a foot long
30 centimeters or so
this is a nanosecond
and to get from here to Voyager is many
many nanoseconds
on the order of 40 hours a round trip to
get to uh to Voyager One and uh and back
these days
so
there was a program put together at JPL
to explore what it would take to have a
a deep space probe and they call this
the thermoelectric outer planets
spacecraft also known as tops
and this had a number of Novel
Technologies one of them was the
self-test and repair computer system
which this had you know triple redundant
components there was a core that had
quintuple five times redundancy and
voting logic you know best two out of
three in order to win in case there was
a failure and I guess if one of the
computers lied I you'd get voted off of
the spacecraft
you also need some way to generate power
you're so far away from the Sun that you
can't build a solar panel and get it
into space that's large enough to
generate the hundreds of Watts that you
need
chemical Solutions you know fuel cells
um might be okay for a short Mission but
not for something lasting a decade so
you reach out to the United States
Department of energy get something with
a little more kick
plutonium
it's glowing because it's hot
plutonium-238 specifically it's an alpha
emitter it has about an 88 year
Half-Life it's a terrific heat Source
you get about a half of a watt per gram
on an ongoing basis just spontaneously
and so you take this plutonium and you
use that to create the mhw the multi 100
watt
radiothermolytic generator which looks
like this I promise this is not a prop
from Doctor Who this is a picture of the
actual RTG unit that was being used on
Voyager inside you have spheres of
plutonium which are then surrounded by a
set of collectors these are
thermocouples it's a solid state device
that can use a temperature differential
and then take that temperature
differential across the junction turn
that directly into direct current into
electricity
and a voyager had enough of these units
three of them just like this to power
about 450 Watts at launch
that ends up using 13 and a half
kilograms of plutonium on top of a
rocket what could possibly go wrong
well there was an intensive safety
program because nobody wants this thing
to land on their house
um
the probe needed to be able the the RTG
needs to be able to uh to survive any
sort of launch accident it also has a
heat shield so it will survive re-entry
into the atmosphere and I just I hope
all that stuff really works in case
something goes wrong with one of these
one day
so The Grand Tour did manage to get a
presidential endorsement President Nixon
in March of 1970 issued a statement on
on space missions and he said we should
ex should move ahead with the Bold
exploration of the outer planets during
the next decade we will launch The Grand
Tour missions to study the mysterious
outer planets of the solar system
Jupiter Saturn Uranus and Neptune and
Pluto preparations for this program
begin in 1972.
while on December 1971
because of the cost of the Vietnam War
some other things that were happening at
Nasa budget wise including the space
shuttle program which was just getting
underway
The Grand Tour was scrubbed from Nash's
NASA's budget
which is the next lesson the endorsement
of the chief executive is no guarantee
that endorsement is sometimes not enough
and this could be the end of the story
except
I'd have too long for questions so
with a with apologies to Paul Harvey I
will now give you the rest of the story
The Grand Tour was an ambitious and
extremely expensive program so the
engineers came back and within 10 days
in 10 days they then proposed a new
reduced scope program a simpler space
probe relying on existing space proven
Hardware
and scope it back to only visit two
planets Jupiter and Saturn and that was
called the Mariner Jupiter Saturn 77
probe
I like to think of this as the MVP or
the minimum viable probe
which the key about this it's cheap
enough to get through Congress
so in May of 1972 funding is approved
and eventually the mission is renamed
Voyager and the Voyager mission is then
set to go for five years
that's the operational lifetime the
design lifetime of the Voyager
spacecraft was five years so it should
have expired in 1982 here it is 2019.
it's still running how is that
Ron Draper was a systems engineer at JPL
and he had this concept called the The X
Factor which was a pretty broad concept
which is effectively don't make any
engineering choices that could limit the
lifetime of the spacecraft
don't make a choice that is going to
limit later freedom of action or as
Donald knuth would put it premature
optimization is the root of all evil
so the three R's of what make a
spacecraft last for this long first you
have reliability you need reliable
components tight design and Fabrication
of the units qualify whatever your
sources are for for components coming in
and have a screening program but
sometimes the components still fail so
you need redundancy on these components
you have spares that are in your system
to work around component failures
and the Voyager program had redundant
computers redundant navigation redundant
communication redundant thrusters
you even had redundant spacecraft
he had Voyager 1 Voyager 2 on two
separate trajectories with different
risk profiles to them
the third R is reconfigurability you
want to be able to take advantage of the
redundancy if you need it
and he can't anticipate everything in
advance of course but once the thing is
launched you can't go out there and fix
it so you need some way to remotely
reconfigure your spacecraft maybe to do
things that you hadn't anticipated in
advance
now it's 1973 we're in the middle of the
design of the of the Voyager probes
we hadn't been to Jupiter yet
and there was a surprise waiting for us
there
which was uh discovered by Pioneer 10.
this is an earlier simpler probe it flew
past Jupiter in December of 1973.
and in what Pioneer showed us was they
were incredibly dense radiation belts
ionizing radiation around Jupiter enough
that it was going to endanger the
spacecraft voyager's original design did
not have any radiation hardening so a
program was then kicked off to add
shielding
have very
careful selection of components
screening qualification of those
components to make sure they were
relatively immune to radiation and also
intensive worst case analysis of the
circuits basically your allowing things
to slow down you're trading off
performance to have extra design margin
in case you do take some some damage
from the radiation
the project did keep on schedule but it
cost 150 million dollars to do this
radiation hardening
fortunately that got funded and we kept
on going and we ended up with this
here's the the Voyager spacecraft all
put together there are 11 scientific
instruments on here plus your power
Communications navigation propulsion
systems
and there are three computer systems
that that tie all of this together
and the systems have these cryptic
acronyms ccs aacs and fds and I'll go
through these um each uh one at a time
the command computer system
this system is always on and this is
really the system that's in charge this
is tied directly into the power system
it controls all the sequencing of all
the major functions of the spacecraft
and those major functions are things
like the power system keeping the
temperature inside you know not too hot
not too cold
attitude and navigation commands are
passed through the the CCS any
instruments that need to be turned on or
off and also the configuration of the
data system to return things through
back through the downlink that's also
managed through the CCS this is an
interrupt driven machine it relies on
timers events that are coming from the
other some subsystems and it will also
respond to any commands that are coming
from the from the up link from Mission
Control
the memories kind of split into two
pieces about half of it is fixed
procedures that typically don't change
these are housekeeping items as well as
any sort of fail-safes that are built in
in case there's lost Communications and
it's not able to receive commands
anymore
now this is all Ram so everything is
reconfigurable there isn't anything that
that's hardwired into the system at all
as far as the uplinked procedures
during a cruise that's typically about
once a month that you'd have something
like that happen during the planetary
encounter there's a lot more going on
and you might see this happen every 18
24 maybe 30 hours that a a new deck of
procedures would get uploaded to uh to
Voyager
Voyager also has autonomous fault
detection it has fixed procedures in
place to detect and respond to uh to any
failures that might happen if something
goes wrong it starts swapping in those
redundant components until things start
to work right again
in fact some folks have compared the the
CCs in Voyager to Hal
fortunately for us the CCs is not
paranoid and it's very good at listening
to instructions and it's also under no
delusion that all of its circuits are
functioning perfectly
so the hardware design of the CCS on
Voyager this is nearly identical to a
previous design already proven in space
that was used on the Viking orbiters
that were launched to Mars in uh in
1975. the computer it's the these
computers it's a dual redundant custom
processor this was designed at jet
propulsion Laboratory
and by redundancy there's two logic
units there's two output units there's
two memories there's two power supplies
there's uh there's two everything and
all of these systems can be
cross-strapped to each other in case of
a failure
architecture-wise these uh these
machines have 18-bit words those 18-bit
words are split into a six-bit opcode
and a 12-bit address it's a direct
addressing machine
any data is kept as 18-bit two's
complement integers and there are 13
registers including you know accumulator
and program counter and there's a status
register and so forth
this is primarily driven by by
interrupts and there are 32 interrupts
that are available to to receive
messages either from command systems or
from other subsystems on the on the
spacecraft
it's built with bipolar TTL logic it has
an 88 microsecond instruction cycle so
it's about 11 000 instructions per
second and memory access in order to
reduce the size of the bus and the the
number of components on board
it takes four Cycles five Cycles on this
machine to get the data out of the
memory because it only grabs things four
bits at a time
the memory itself is made of of what
they call plated wire memory it's
in principle a lot like a magnetic core
memory except that there are no cores
it's actually a magnetic coating that's
on wire
the bits are stored on there as magnetic
fields it's non-volvital the reeds are
non-destructive and it's largely immune
to uh to radiation
it's not fast but that's not really a
design requirement for this
programming on Voyager this is a pretty
raw environment there's no operating
system
I think it was all done in Assembly
Language there's a couple of references
that talk about Fortran I haven't been
able to convince myself that um the CCS
was actually programmed in Fortran um
but but perhaps it was
the second system is the articulation
and uh sorry the attitude and
articulation control system
this is a separate system it's largely
based on the same Hardware as the as the
CCS this is the system that keeps the
spacecraft pointed in the right
direction and operates the the
instruments that are on the scan
platform this uh you know to access arm
that that's hanging off the side which
holds the the Imaging instruments
the the CCs is really the what to do the
aacs handles the uh the how to do it as
far as how to run the servos and how
fast to move things how to run the
thrusters and so forth
the main job of the aacs is take that
that giant dish that you know three and
a half four meter dish on the front keep
that pointed back at Earth so we can
keep communicating with this thing
the only time it doesn't do that is in
case of a mid-course correction or maybe
they need to do something for Imaging
where the dish is in the way
and then it has to be able to get that
pointed back so we can re-establish
Communications
now the aacs is also two redundant
computers only one of them is going to
be on at a time
like I said the hardware was the same as
the CCS except there was actually one
more component it was a piece of logic
that was stuffed between the the
processor and the memory to give you
indexed addressing modes
which then gave you the capability to
reduce you know some duplicate code that
you uh that you might have on this uh on
this processor
um this processor has a number of
interesting peripherals to help it keep
pointed and you know take the actions
that it needs to do
and it's actually quite a bit different
from Data Systems that we might have had
on on previous probes
we used to do this just entirely with
with analog circuits
in Voyager we had a digital computer
that had a huge Advantage because now
you can change things after launch if
there's some sort of problem where you
need to enhance the system the
capability is uh is there to uh to do
that including working around any of
these uh if any of these peripherals
fail you want to be able to program the
machine or have it respond in order to
uh to work around that
the third major system is the flight
data system this is what really manages
the The Collection formatting
transmission and uh and storage of any
data that's collected
and the data in this case is really
three types there's data that's coming
from the instruments themselves there's
data related to to Imaging which gives
us those great pictures we get back and
then there's so-called engineering data
which is really about the health of the
spacecraft itself
now this machine was not like the other
two this was a brand new design
they needed something that was fast
enough in order to handle the the data
volumes that they that they were looking
to uh process now this was based on
metal oxide semiconductors CMOS this was
the first time that a CMOS computer was
going into space
this is a a nibble cereal 16-bit word
two and a half microsecond cycle time it
takes four Cycles to do a fetch then one
more cycle to actually execute the
instruction so you get a cycle a new
instruction every 12 and a half
microseconds so that's 80 000
instructions per second that can be run
on here the memory is not plated wire
memory it's also CMOS memory in this uh
in this system
is faster but it's volatile and it's
really susceptible to radiation so as
part of the radiation hardening process
there was just a ton of shielding not
literally a ton but a lot of shielding
put around this uh the system
now
something I didn't know until I
researched this is when Voyager is
operating and it's going through its
Imaging and its measurements during an
encounter it's retaining it's returning
most of that data through the downlink
in real time because the amount of
storage on Voyager is so limited you
really want to be able to grab
everything just as things are being
measured and get that right away now
this means that there's no retry which
means you can't really tolerate a whole
lot of errors
but you're talking about something
that's a really long ways away it's a
noisy Channel and you need to have some
way in order to insulate yourself
against uh errors that are that are
coming in because of of noise or
whatever and so there is a form of
forward error correction
um it's called golay encoding this is
basically a a type of parity that's
being done every 12 bits of data are
then tacked together with 12 bits of
parity this gives you the capability in
each of those 12-bit blocks to recover
from any three bits having been flipped
and that was able to uh to raise the
reliability of the the transmission get
the error rate low enough to uh to an
acceptable level
but there is a penalty for that which is
you double the amount of data that you
need to uh to send down but there is a
trade-off statistically then you can you
can then run a faster data rate because
the uh the total error rate is going to
be sufficiently lower
now sometimes you need to record things
and they get recorded on tape
not that tape it was an eight-track tape
not that eight-track tape it was this
eight-track tape
so Voyager has this tape drive in it if
for some reason it can't relay the data
live streamed what it's going to do
instead is dump that data to the tape it
might be because of something that they
have to do for Imaging maybe you're
behind a moon or a planet
this tape it's about a thousand feet
long holds 500 megabits that's enough
for about a hundred full resolution
images from the Imaging system on
Voyager
and then the tape is rewound and played
back for uh when we're back in contact
with the ground stations again
Voyager zero turns out there's actually
three spacecraft built not just two
the first one that was delivered was an
engineering prototype
and if you want to go see that it's now
in the National Air and Space Museum the
uh this engineering prototype was
especially handy when you are trying to
you know troubleshoot between you know
three systems as I mean there aren't
very many of these you can't go to stack
Overflow and you know ask what's going
on with it
um
so you're able to troubleshoot by well
how is it working in the other system
and this actually happened several times
in the you know couple of month period
leading up to the launch after these uh
the spacecraft had been had been shipped
so
we're finally at launch designs all done
Voyager 2 launches first August 20th
1977 a couple of weeks later Voyager 1
launches that's September 5th of 1977.
Voyager 1 is on a faster path and so
it's going to get to Jupiter first
now post launch
there were some issues at jet propulsion
laboratory in managing the mission
um
there was an incident where
and I think it was because
Engineers were being assigned to other
tasks getting direct distracted by work
going on in the Galileo program which
was a follow-on to Voyager there was a
command That was supposed to get sent to
Voyager 2 because he needed to talk to
it every week
and somebody forgot to send that command
so the autonomous fault protection on
the spacecraft said well I haven't heard
from ground in a while uh I timed out at
168 hours let's switch to the other
receiver something must have gone wrong
it runs the uh the lost command routine
so it switches to the secondary receiver
secondary receiver Power It Up there's a
shorted capacitor in the phased lock
loop of this receiver the receiver still
works but not very well it doesn't track
frequencies very well anymore
so a command is then sent up to Voyager
to switch back to the primary receiver
that receiver runs for 17 minutes
experiences a short and the power supply
blows the fuses dead
now you need to wait another 168 hours
to get the spacecraft to listen to you
again after the lost command procedure
runs a second time switches back to the
secondary receiver we're still running
on this receiver that doesn't listen
very well
um it's very sensitive to temperature on
the spacecraft and Doppler shift and so
forth so the um Folks at the deep space
network with the giant satellite dishes
that are used to talk to these probes
they have a uh they have a procedure by
which they sweep through a series of
frequencies to try to figure out which
one Voyager 2 is listening on the
listening on the best
so I think the lesson here is don't
neglect your project after the launch
I think this had been sort of a wake-up
call to the to the management at JPL the
project did get back on track and so by
the time we got the Jupiter
um things were really in much better
shape
and so Jupiter Saturn the moon Titan for
for Voyager One all of those encounters
went great um likewise for Voyager 2.
after the Titan encounter Voyager 1 was
sent North out of the ecliptic it's not
going to ever encounter another plant
and planet in our solar system Voyager 2
though based on the success of the
program thus far they managed to get
more funding and that kept going on to
Uranus and Neptune but there's an
impending problem as you're approaching
Uranus is the further you get away the
weaker the signal gets the weaker the
signal is the less bandwidth that you
have
you only have one chance to capture this
data too because you don't have any
storage to speak of on the spacecraft
so if you want to get all the pictures
that you want and all the other data
scientific data you need to have some
way to augment the the bandwidth of that
and so
what was done there was to implement a
data compression algorithm this was not
part of the original design at all this
is used for compressing the images
ordinarily that flight data system only
one of those systems would be running
now we're using both of them in parallel
one to process the
um the general science data and the
other one is now processing the the
image data and compressing it you get
about a two to one ratio of compression
out of that
and they also kicked into there a Reed
Solomon encoder which is a different
type of forward error correction system
uh Reed Solomon has less of an overhead
uh compared to uh to go lay it's about a
15 overhead of bits but again that was
able to give reliable enough
Communications to get enough images
enough data off of the spacecraft
now as this is getting further and
further away from us what we're finding
is uh Voyager we're getting you know
it's it's tougher and tougher to to
communicate with it
but we're able to adjust data rates and
keep that going of course the hydrazine
fuel that's used for the for the
thrusters there's enough of that to last
for probably a couple of more decades
but really what's going to be the
limiting factor on this probe is power
the radiothermolytic generator is
suffering two effects one of them is the
um just the the half-life of the
plutonium
um or you know halfway through the first
half-life of that plutonium at this
point
but the other thing that happens is
those those thermocouples do eventually
degrade and you get less power out of
those thermocouples
so what we've been able to do is keep
things running by turning off
instruments turning heaters on and off
in order to try to modulate the amount
of power that we have in the in the
spacecraft
and I mean really estimates are we're
only going to be able to operate this
probably for about the next five years
or so
at which point the spacecraft will fall
silent
but they've already reached solar escape
velocity so they're not coming back
they're going to keep going out into the
great beyond
maybe land someplace somewhere out in
the galaxy
and on Voyager is this golden record
this is a recording of images and sounds
and greetings from the earth who knows
this might get found one of these days
and and somebody will you know decode
this and have themselves a little
message uh from here uh from us here on
Earth
so that's my talk I have a couple of
minutes for uh for questions
um so uh go ahead and shoot
thank you
go ahead
uh okay the specs of the camera
um this was a camera that was based on a
vidicon tube which is a is a vacuum tube
based camera it's something that would
have been uh in regular television
cameras back in the say the 60s or 70s
in that era this was before digital
sensors really became widely available
it's able to uh it's a it's a square
frame 800 by 800 pixels and so you get a
640 megapixel image
eight levels of gray there wasn't any
color capability native to the tube
itself
instead there was a color wheel that was
in front of the camera that would cycle
through I think they had eight different
filters
um colors plus also some things for like
methane to try to do some Imaging there
right there
um I I haven't uh the question was about
how much has the redundancy of the
computers been used I I think really
thankfully not very much I'm not aware
of a computer system having completely
rolled over there there have been some
issues with single bit failures in some
of the some of the CMOS memories on the
flight data system I know that they have
been doing some programming to uh to try
to work around those single bit failures
but as far as a complete Wipeout I am
not aware of one
right here
okay question was about the the team uh
currently working on Voyager I I did see
one number
um and this this number is actually a
couple of years old I think it was about
14 people working on Voyager I'm I'm not
sure if that includes the support from
the uh from the deep space Network who's
running all the communications
um but it's it's a pretty small team
these days
uh back there
okay the uh that question was
um are we expecting the uh uh the the
communications the fail or the hardware
to fail as far as the communications
goes
um
the flight data system is really
configurable to run it lower and lower
data rates so I think we are able to at
least keep getting things back
um there really isn't any more
high-speed data coming back from Voyager
because the the Imaging platform was
turned off you know 30 years ago
I think the the one unit that everybody
is watching and trying to manage is the
is the radio thermolytic generator and
the the Power Systems
uh right here
um I have that on the first slide
actually
uh
can I get back there
um you know I'm not going to look it up
I think it's around 40 hours
uh right there
I wasn't able to get a lot of
information on that I I do know that
they have prototype systems uh in the
lab basically a copy of of all of these
systems but as far as like a you know a
software engineering approach there
there wasn't a whole lot that I could
find that was uh that was written on
that unfortunately
right there
[Music]
okay
um so the uh the the original Mission
and of course these are about 1970
dollars uh was somewhere between 750 and
900 million dollars the uh the reduced
Mission
um was originally funded for it was
around 250 million uh as far as
affecting the hardware it meant that
things like the the star computer which
the engineers thought was a really
elegant solution that ended up getting
thrown overboard and then they ended up
using you know other Hardware that they
that they originally had
um
I think the ultimate cost of the program
eventually grew because the the program
had been extended and it probably cost
around 900 million dollars by the time
that we you know get to now
um anyway
um
I mean a question about you know
extending you know the The Grand Tour I
mean Uranus and Neptune Voyager 2 went
there we haven't been back since uh I
think the the other really deep space
mission you know a couple of years ago
New Horizons uh visited uh Pluto and you
know that was that was something uh just
really you know terrific to watch
because it was sort of like the The
Rebirth of getting something that you
could never otherwise get
um
but uh I I get your questions
sufficiently
okay thanks uh right there
I should I haven't put it together yet
um but I'll try to get that posted on my
GitHub
oh
um I I have a stack of things I've
printed out like this I just need to get
all the URLs posted I got a couple more
right here
um
okay this was a uh question about
physical failure mode of the
thermocouples
I I didn't try to unwind the
semiconductor physics
um behind that unfortunately so I I I
don't understand that one yet
okay
uh right here
um I think it's about every couple of
months this is the frequency of the the
maintenance updates to uh to Voyager
there's not a whole lot of Maintenance
to do because
um I mean the the measurements are sort
of ongoing and they're they're pretty
static uh it's really any management
that they want to do of the power system
um but I think it's every couple three
months that they're doing an uplink
that was one over there
ah
okay uh are there alternatives to an RTG
um something that's going to last a
couple of decades
and provide this amount of power for
something that's that far away from the
Sun
um I I don't think there is one as uh I
mean even in missions that we're
launching now Cassini and New Horizons
they were also using rtgs so
unfortunately I don't think there's a
better alternative yet
uh right here
yes
um the question was uh time division on
the deep space Network
um I I do know that they do have a a
schedule
I mean the team working on Voyager I
imagine that part of their job is
managing the sequencing of when data is
going to be transmitted back and so I'm
sure that those resources are are
managed
um but I I do know that they can't just
sit there and listen to it all the time
uh one more quick one uh right here
you know there's any Security on the
date whoever has a big antenna can talk
about yeah security I could find no
information about the security which
either means there isn't any or it's
classified I'm not sure which
okay my time's up um this is great thank
you very much
[Applause]